this country's success is built by
working people but the tax system is
loaded against them the prime minister
may not understand the pressures facing
families across the country but we do
and the reality is this taxes on working
people up
national insurance
council tax up
energy bills food prices burdens on
families up up up
the prime minister mr speaker needs to
get real
and understand the terrible impact of
his decisions on working people across
this country
mr speaker this afternoon
he has the chance to change course to
vote with labour to cancel a cut to
universal credit and then to stop
clobbering working people with unfair
tax rises will he do so
[Applause]
well mr speaker let me let me tell uh i
think you see the panto season
which
country or all order order if it is it's
certainly behind you prime minister
well let me ask you mr speaker since
you're a man of great restraint and
taste uh and judgment uh which country
has the fastest growth in the g7
where is
where is employment up to mr speaker
where are job vacancies at the highest
level
mr speaker
as for wages mr speaker they are
higher than they were before the
pandemic i've listened to i listened to
the right honourable uh gentleman very
carefully over the last uh over the last
fortnight i'm told that he has a
000 word essay in gestation uh mr
speaker i don't i don't know why he
can't produce it uh right away i mean
why does the world have to wait for the
the thoughts of
chairman of chairman kier
having having listened having listened
uh to what he's had to say uh his
non-existent plan for for benefits for
universal credit his non-existent plan
uh for health and social care i can
compress those fourteen thousand words
to four mr speaker vote labour wait
longer
that's what he stands for mr speaker
our plan for jobs is working mr speaker
our plan for kobe is working